[Applaudissements]
voilà les images
catastrophiques alors en Paris les
vitrines d'une concession BMW ont été
brisés par des casseurs et le magasin
était pillés les images font le tour des
réseaux sociaux depuis quelques minutes
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
incroyable incroyable c'est fou
en fait alors il casse mes abîmes tous
les plus beaux messages je remarque
quand même que dans toutes les
manifestations il y a pas il y a pas il
y a pas des casseurs en fait quand il y
a la marche pour le climat il y a pas de
casseurs quand il y a la marche pour la
violence faite aux femmes alors qu'il y
a beaucoup plus de monde qu'avec la CGT
aujourd'hui il y a pas de casseurs et
moi je pensais que la CGT ils avaient un
service de sécurité béton armé parce
qu'à l'époque des gilets jaunes on
disait les gilets jaunes ils ont pas de
service de sécurité donc c'est un peu
compliqué pour pour eux de juguler les
casseurs la CGT normalement ils sont
béton armés avec la sécurité visiblement
là ils ont été complètement
on peut comprendre leur revendication
après
tu sois responsable
Géraldine de faire le lien parce que
honnêtement c'est 200 à 300 casseurs
professionnels
que même les policiers il y a des
cellules d'enquête spécialisées
n'arrivent pas à démanteler ils sont
hyper organisés ils viennent pour casser
et ils viennent justement pour entre
guillemets ridiculiser la CG montrer que
les revendications ne sont pas loin donc
ils viennent briser les les bonnes idées
où on peut les juger contraire mais
enfin les idées de la CGT sont
vilipendées par ces gens-là je les
déteste ces blagues c'est inadmissible
commerçants il y a une autre image qui a
été très très commentée sur les réseaux
elle a été tournée environ vers 17h30 on
peut voir deux policiers attaqués par un
groupe de manifestants qui veulent aller
au contact avec les forces de l'ordre
regarder
[Musique]
son compte Twitter un homme a été blessé
à l'oeil il s'agirait du journaliste
Zakaria Abdelkafi qui aurait été touché
au niveau de l'arcade sourcilière
regardez
[Musique]
[Rires]
je suis là
il va aller mieux voilà et plutôt dans
la journée c'est un journaliste de BFM
TV qui a été chassé d'une manifestation
des étudiants qui ne voulaient pas je
cite d'une télé qui relie de fausses
informations regarde
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'était pas violent
alors les images ou les avez vu comme je
disais c'est contre-productif totalement
ce qui s'est passé et c'est vrai qu'à la
base beaucoup de gens c'était voilà
beaucoup de gens étaient pour 100% des
des salaires sur l'inflation Jamel
Debbouze d'ailleurs apporté son soutien
aux salariés en grève et à dénoncé les
profits des patrons regardez
que je peux vous dire c'est que j'ai pu
constater que effectivement il y avait
un creusé un fossé qui se croisait
davantage entre entre les riches et les
pauvres il y a plein d'endroits où on a
le sentiment que les choses s'affaisse
un petit peu et qui a vraiment de
considération je pense que c'est un
ras-le-bol général c'est effectivement
de pas pouvoir remplir son frigo ça
c'est intolérable surtout dans un pays
riche comme la France on comprend pas ça
et puis et puis effectivement avoir le
sentiment de ne pas être écouté c'est ce
qui a de pire dans la vie d'être nié
c'est ce qui se passe
on entend la France grondée de plus en
plus et c'est ce qu'elle crie j'ai
l'impression de 1998 et de Zinédine
Zidane ah bah oui la France où j'ose pas
Chirac marchait main dans la main la
France ou le Front national était au
plus bas la France ou les caisses
étaient pleines oui on a assez loin de
cette France
alors il y a Patrick pouyani le patron
de Total énergie qui a mis un truc
aujourd'hui je suis fatigué de cette
accusation de mettre augmenter de 52 %
voici la vraie évolution de ma
rémunération depuis 2017 elle est
constante sauf en 2020 car j'ai
volontairement amputé mon salaire et ma
part variable a normalement baissé avec
les résultats de Total énergie donc il a
mis un graphique avec tous ces salaires
depuis 2017 je vais vous dire moi je
sais pas ce que vous en pensez moi je
voilà il fait si voilà sa boîte marche
il gagne beaucoup d'argent à peu près
mais je pense que ce qu'on ce que
veulent les salariés c'est juste être
augmenté voilà qu'est-ce qu'il demande
pas énormément il demande vraiment voilà
être indexé sur le sur le pouvoir
d'achat sur le sur le l'inflation parce
que forcément leur pouvoir d'achat avec
l'inflation ils s'envoient vraiment
amputé donc voilà c'est vraiment c'est
c'est pour ça et donc voilà c'est ça
qu'on c'est ça que les gens lui
reprochent c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
tant que ça rémunération oui bien sûr
c'est oui mais c'est en contrepartie
même pas en contrepartie c'est juste que
voilà de pouvoir vivre normalement
voilà et on en parlait hier avec les
personnes de la RATP de la SNCF vous
voyez ou pas les salaires à 1600 1700
euros alors c'est au dessus du salaire
médian mais c'est quand même je vous dis
aujourd'hui c'est de plus en plus
compliqué de pouvoir s'en sortir et
c'est vrai que il faudrait indexer tous
les salons vraiment
sur l'inflation parce que sinon les gens
peuvent pas plus vivre à partir du 15 du
mois voilà donc cette manifestation elle
est importante malheureusement elle a
été gâchée par 200 à 300 casseurs